al momento de hablar de economía en
france 24 y por ello le doy la
bienvenida a nuestra periodista experta
daniela blandón daniela iniciamos en
colombia donde renunció el equipo
económico por la caída de la reforma
tributaria cuéntenos andrés muy buenas
noches primero que todo el presidente e
iván duque le aceptó la renuncia al
ministro alberto carrasquilla y nombró
en su reemplazo al ministro de comercio
jose manuel restrepo pero también
dimitió buena parte del equipo que ayudó
a estructurar el fallido proyecto de
reforma tributaria que generó protestas
masivas se trata de los dos
viceministros de hacienda y el director
de planeación nacional
pero andrés este complejo panorama por
el que atraviesa el país tiene
repercusiones también para el bolsillo
de la nación un experto nos va a
explicar por qué luego ya nos financia
por ejemplo emitiendo bonos entre ellos
de ustedes alrededor del 25 por ciento
de la tenencia en este tipo de
instrumentos es de los agentes
internacionales por lo tanto en momentos
como los actuales estos inversionistas
internacionales deciden vender este tipo
de instrumentos y retirar sus capitales
de nuestro país lo que a su vez genera
una sobredemanda
en el corto plazo lo que tiene como
efecto en el corto plazo una fuerte
apreciación del dólar estadounidense
respecto al peso colombiano
daniela y vamos a méxico que registró un
nuevo récord de remesas en marzo si
señor la mayoría de las remesas en este
país recordemos proviene de muchos de
los 38 millones de mexicanos que hoy
viven en eeuu en marzo las remesas
llegaron a más de 4 mil millones de
dólares
provenientes del exterior más del 30 por
ciento por encima de lo que había
llegado en el mismo mes del año pasado y
en el primer trimestre acumuló más de 10
mil millones de dólares esto representa
un aumento del 13 por ciento como vemos
en el gráfico andrés daniela de vamos a
chile porque hubo largas filas en el
primer día del tercer retiro de
pensiones en las dos primeras
oportunidades que fueron en julio y en
diciembre la mayoría de los 11 millones
de afiliados al sistema retiró casi 38
mil millones de dólares pues hasta el
mediodía de este lunes las
administradoras de fondos de pensiones
ya reportaban más de 2 millones de
solicitudes
avalancha de gente queriendo echar mano
de lo que les queda de ahorro provisión
previsional es el reflejo de la
desesperada situación económica de
muchos ciudadanos en este país
con este nuevo retiro de hasta el 10% de
los fondos de cada afiliado el gobierno
dice que casi la mitad de ellos se va a
quedar sin salto y daniela inició el
juicio entre apple y la desarrolladora
de videojuegos de epic games si andrés
los abogados del gigante tecnológico y
el desarrollador del popular juego for
night expusieron hoy sus argumentos ante
un tribunal federal de california epic
games se queja de las comisiones de
hasta el 30% que cobra su contraparte
por las transacciones a través de su
tienda a postor que es la única
accesible en iphone o en iphone o en
ipad o en ipad asegura también que
bloquea ilegalmente la competencia a
paul le responde que lo que busca su
demandante es deshacerse de las
comisiones para elevar sus propias
ganancias y que construir su tienda de
aplicaciones le ha costado más de 100
mil millones de dólares en todo caso
andrés a este juicio que se espera se
extienda por tres semanas va a sentar un
precedente
relación entre los fabricantes de
celulares y los desarrolladores de hecho
de james tiene demandado a google por el
mismo motivo en el momento de conocer
los indicadores wall street' del cerro
mixto con los inversionistas apostando
por la recuperación económica las
acciones europeas cerraron al alza
después de que la comisión europea
anunciara planes para relajar las
restricciones sobre el turismo y en
américa latina la bolsa de chile avanzó
más del 2% en el primer día de retiro de
pensiones y nuestra cifra del día
130.000 millones de dólares
esa es la fortuna de bill gates el
fundador de microsoft y cuarto hombre
más rico del mundo según la revista
forbes este lunes anunció su separación
de melinda gates quienes de acuerdo con
la misma publicación la quinta mujer más
poderosa del mundo ambos crearon en el
2000 la fundación benéfica más grande
del planeta total de 40 mil millones de
dólares pues este divorcio andrés puede
competir perfectamente por uno de los
más caros de la historia cuando el
fundador de amazon jeff bezos y mckenzie
squad se separaron en 2019 ella
la cuarta parte de participación de
pesos en la empresa hoy amasa una
fortuna de 59.000 millones de dólares y
es la número 22 en la lista de
billonarios del mundo daniela muchas
gracias por traernos la información
económica aquí en france 24 y ustedes
muchas gracias por acompañarnos
continúen con toda nuestra programación
[Música]